[Musica]
lo so ragazzi che sembra una copia
sputata di vin diesel costo fisico però
non è nenè che ho fatto palestra maggio
soltanto tipo 750 magliette addosso non
è normale lo so che trent a fine video
come mai ci sono finito così non è non è
per caso lo vedrete poi dopo se no mi
dispiace mi vado a cambiare perché mi
sto leggermente sciogliendo a dopo
quella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
avessero video sono fuori j
ed oggi siamo in un nuovo blog con tommy
carica di questa frase non avete prima
di cominciare ragazzi come al solito
l'idea iniziale cosa fate la settimana
quante cazzo di volte sto facendo così
poiché ciò dei tic quando faccio queste
cose ma non lo so come mai lo faccio più
che ragazzi la parte della settimana è
stata vinta da federica che ha fatto
questo questo disegno fantastico una
parte la mia mano sembra quella tipo di
di iron man mano sempre che è fantastica
più che ragazzi di ripartire più le
chiuso perché ne ho un casino di nome da
dirvi allora prima di tutto primissima
cosa 950 mila iscritti raggiunti ragazzi
è fantastico non ce la faccio a
realizzare ste cose non è possibile sono
rimasto ancora il periodo in cui dice
volge tipo 10.000 iscritti cazzo è
impossibile quindi 950 yacht è veramente
quando prova a realizzare ste cose che
sapevo quello che mi tira addosso
qualcosa per svegliarmi perché non è
possibile grazie prima di iniziare
quello scattati fa che tutto il resto
volevo dirvi un paio di co un paio di
cose la prima ragazze che ogni tanto
raramente per ogni tanto capita che
magari un giorno non pubblico qualcosa
si chiude ragazzi nonostante io stia
facendo vi do al giorno ogni tanto
raramente proprio per ogni tanto magari
capita che un giorno non pubblico
qualcosa è semplicemente per il fatto
che anch'io in teoria essendo un essere
umano sono in vacanza quindi magari ogni
tanto un giorno me lo prendo anch'io e
soltanto per il periodo di agosto ma in
genere un video al giorno c'è ovviamente
quasi sempre e volevo anche iniziare
magari a fare video ogni tanto magari
anche di sera quando capiterà perché in
questo periodo è un casino però quando
capiterà ogni tanto magari uscirà mai
capito più breve ma anche di sera per
chi come me lo chiedi in tanti magari
ogni tanto un video in più ci può stare
quindi non vi preoccupate l'ultimo caso
ragazze che praticamente ho tolto il
punto posta qui non c'è più sicuro
ragazzi ancora un miliardo di pacchi la
prima infatti nel prossimo blog credo di
aprire un casinò come la scorsa volta
appena avrà smaltito t park i ragazzi vi
dirò nuovo indirizzo così almeno gli
inviati agli perché se non ritorno
la cosa in via tavo di prima detto
questo ragazzine che possiamo passare
appunto allo scarto delle parti alla
luce di quello che ho appena detto dei
baci che stanno prendendo controllo
della mia vita
giudicate voi questo cosa cazzo può
ormai essere dice mio io allora il
postino che si è portato stomaci note ma
che forse può sembrare che sia accaduto
qualcosa ma non è accaduto niente giorni
devi partire ragazzi dal più piccolo
perché quella roba norme non so quanto
posso metterci alla prima ma io voglio
sapere gli archeologi del futuro che
scaveranno nella mia casa che cazzo ci
trovano con tutti stì fatti le 100
milioni di lettere la nutella fantastico
no che figurano per una volta non
c'erano i giornali ma c'erano schifosi
che sono morbidosi che ho trovati a
miskolc a gatto addosso maraga minchia
stanotte stanotte vado dai miei mentre
dormono mazzo telo registrarla sta cosa
il bug e dopo quanti se ne sono visti
così non lo so ma mi divertirò parecchio
da anche una maglietta con una fan
articolo lander dentro la mute 9 questa
questa è fantastica cioè ragazzi siamo
al secondo per grandezza c'è veramente
questo non è neanche più grande sacco
tempo strana prova bene ho messo 40
minuti ad aprile sta roba
ma lo avreste mai detto
un pacco in un pacco fantastici sono
giornali ragazzi e c'è anche un'altra
scatola perché ci sono scatole su
scatole non finirà mai una cosa secondo
me a parte il fatto che c'è scritto che
c'è ti aspettavi pornografia e poi c'è
una pallina così lo rai non è che mi
aspettavo pornografia però cosa mi
rappresenta questa cosa di precise c'è
un pacco che è grosso 10 volte alla mia
testa più o meno e dentro c'è questo
perché
[Musica]
quindi ragazzini passera l'ultimo kwaku
che però se una macchina
spero un peso messo negli anni ragazzi
per aprirlo ma finalmente c'è allora io
non ho mai visto una cosa più bella che
sia qualcosa tipo il mio background
quello del canale quello su cartoncino è
qualcosa di fantastico grazie mille
ragazzi ma a parte gli scherzi ma ma
sull'inter non sembra tipo un modello
delle ber combi e qualcosa del genere è
troppo un film e dunque ragazzine che
possiamo passare al fa vi risponderà
prima andrà ghazi mi chiede fa risponde
ma da dove arriva il tuo cane di peluche
che ogni tanto appare nei video preso
che intenda questo cane di peluche alla
prima inter ragazzi questo questo il
cane si chiama cornhill stato prevede il
mio primo peluche di quando ero piccolo
quindi rimette da bambino per
addormentarmi mi addormentavo insieme
perché non dormivo sono dormivo con
questo quindi ci dormivo una voce non è
che ne so ci dormi se cazzo su 19 anni
ma non lo sanno
via peer glielo domani ti faccio dormire
per terra
giuro tgv è mia di gemonio
poi mi spieghi come si pronuncia story
chimei poi risponde a cavi perché non
fai un video dove rispondi solo ai vari
risponde allora interesse ho pensato a
sta cosa
la francia ha fatto in passato stato
dalla se volete la riffa fatemi sapere
cosa ne pensate se volete lari faccio
volentieri dopo aver smaltito i pacchi
però perché se non mi ami mi fanno un
attentato durante la notte credo quante
magliette riesce ad indossare la
rapidità ragazzi sta sfida me l'avete
fatta a tipo mesi secoli fa va beh vi
avevo detto che avrei ritrovato a farlo
ci riprovo ragazzi vediamo quante
mariette respira indossando amico non
tremo fatte nascosto blog forse tipo una
decina vediamo se riesco a fare di
meglio
via 123456 e con questi ragazzi mi sento
tipo un bodyguard è se non la cosa più
bella che mi si stanno scompigliando i
capelli ogni volta che metto la
maglietta quindi record non è tanto poi
mai a tema quanto riesco scompigli armi
capelli quello ci riesco 8 9 10 sto
morendo di caldo in una maniera che non
potete capire ma mi mettevi scioglierò
prima di toglierle quindi se non vi
trovate più sapete perché 11 12 13 14
non ce la faccio più rega 15 16 o mio
fermi un attimo mi sento walk così la
cosa impressionante permette 17 18 19 20
basta ragazzi basta non ce la posso più
fare sto morendo è fantastico perché per
camminare devo fare una roba tipo e
adesso ho mangiato anch'io al mcdonald
si vede c'è una cosa che il santissimo o
poi comunque ragazzino a fare la stessa
cosa vuoi pantaloni se riesco e proverò
a ribattere il mio record perché per ora
mi sono formato qui perchè giuro ho sto
soffocando anche se non si vede direi
che posso chiudere più vita di se riesco
a trovare il telecomando dove cazzo mi
ha messo a eccolo scusata secondo me ho
preso cinque o sei chili con sta roba
addosso minimo con che ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto come sei se non avete
abbastanza maglietta lasciati come al
solito un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e con i video tratta
nella descrizione che è difficile
muovere il braccio però sarebbe
restituisca temi noi ci rimettiamo al
prossimo video e non farmi incazzare
belle ragazze culo aria amica che
gomitata alla scrivania